sortie de crise en israël après seize
mois d'une impasse politique sans
précédent un accord a enfin été trouvé
hier pour former un gouvernement le
premier ministre israélien benyamin
netanyahou et son extrême à la d league
en se sont entendus les deux parties se
sont donc mis d'accord sur un pacte
d'une durée de trois ans ils vont former
un gouvernement bis partisans avec cas
pour un premier ministre benyamin
nétanyahou pour les 18 premiers mois
béni cance le remplacera pour les 18
mois suivant nous avons empêché une
quatrième élection nous avons protéger
la démocratie
nous combattrons la couronne et nous
nous préoccuperons de tous les citoyens
d'israël
nous avons un gouvernement d'union
d'urgence j'ai promis à l'état d'israël
un gouvernement national d'urgence qui
travaillerait pour sauver la vie et les
moyens de subsistance des citoyens
israéliens
je continuerai à tout faire pour vous
citoyens d'israël
alors comment réagissent case israélien
on écouta michelle stein correspondant
de la chaîne israélienne cannes
je pense que la plupart des gens
souhaitent un gouvernement d'union après
500 jours sans gouvernement après trois
élections
la plupart des israéliens veulent un
gouvernement capable d'agir
nous sommes un domaine qui couronna
virus il nous n'avons même pas de budget
pour la plupart des gens souhaitent
ardemment un nouveau gouvernement
mais il ya des gens qui préféraient un
gouvernement sans benyamin nétanyahou
ils sont conscients que c'est le seul
gouvernement possible aujourd'hui ni
gants cela dit lui-même il s'agit d'une
situation d'urgence est bel est bien que
j'ai dit par le passé que je ne lirai
pas à benyamin nétanyahou carriles et
sonic taille des accusations heures bien
que j'ai dit qu'il nous avait plus le
premier ministre au vu de la situation
je suis disposé à gouverner avec lui
c'est ce qu'il a dit beaucoup de gens
sur lui même
mais il ne voulait plus daigné me
netanyahu mais d'urgence il faut avancer
aucune lettre comme teigneux